[Music]
so a couple of days ago Collider did a
screening of Avengers infinity war with
the Russo brothers and did a Q&A with
the Russo brothers after there was high
hopes that we would get some sort of
information about Avengers 4 about the
trailer about the title anything sadly
we did not but they did answer a lot of
great questions about Avengers infinity
war and they did clear a lot of things
up I did a video yesterday on the full
Q&A breakdown you can check it out in
the link above but I left one question
and answer out because I wanted to talk
about it individually and that question
is about Stormbreaker as it turns out
our idea of how strong Stormbreaker is
is a little off in Avengers infinity war
right after fan o's collected all of the
stones we saw thor hidden with lightning
and then he three Stormbreaker at him
then Thanos tried to combat the attack
with what seemed like the full force of
the Infinity Gauntlet
but Stormbreaker beat the attack of the
Infinity Gauntlet went through it and
hit Thanos in the chest so naturally we
all thought that Stormbreaker
is stronger than the Infinity Gauntlet
well as it turns out that's not the case
thanks to the QA we learned a little bit
more here's what the Russo brothers had
to say about it
they said that Thanos didn't know what
was coming his way when Thor came out of
a storm breaker and if he had he would
have been able to use the stones to
better react so it's not that storm
breaker is stronger than the Infinity
Gauntlet and the Infinity stones
it's that Thanos was really caught off
guard Thanos had just collected the last
Infinity stone to complete his quest for
all six he hadn't even fully taken in
the full power of the Infinity Gauntlet
when Thor attacked him so he was super
surprised by the attack and his response
was sort of a panic attack he wasn't
able to launch a typical smart and
calculated Thanos attack there's no
doubt that Stormbreaker isn't a
massively powerful weapon it's the
weapon for the king of Asgard and can
even summon the Bifrost like we saw in
Avengers infinity war but as it turns
out according to the Russo brothers it
is not stronger than the Infinity
Gauntlet with all six Infinity stones so
it looks like Thor is going to have to
do more than just go for the head in
Avengers 4
you should have gone for the head so
that's it for this video on Stormbreaker
let me know your thoughts down below on
the Infinity Gauntlet being stronger
than Stormbreaker
if you'd like to enter my giveaway for a
chance to win a copy of Infinity Ward
the art of the movie art book infinity
war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]